let's check in with of where do we want
to go let's try the two one seven area
code who's calling today from two one
seven hi David
hi who's this so my name is Ann 26 year
old truck driver
sorry Pierre my truck background I have
to hopefully you don't hear it alright
no problem
what are those are those stick shifts or
are they all automatic these days oh
this trucks automatic I hate it anyway
okay I'm not necessarily coming to you
today with a question so much as I would
just like to throw a different maybe a
different opinion at you and maybe she
could think about because in my own
personal view and come I've only been
following politics for the last year and
a half two years I noticed something
that really does bother me about this
country everybody has their own idea as
to what they think the problem is with
this country one of the things that I
think because probably could be
pinpointed is one of the biggest
problems with this country is that
America has become too complete
but this current form of politics I
noticed that you and Tom Hart both made
videos explaining how Trump's legacy is
going to outlast them and my first
thought is okay but why do they have to
now let me explain I personally believe
that the president being the president
of the United States is still a job
because at the end of the day it is sure
and if someone is not performing up to
standard at their job in any other place
of employment they lose that job right
whereas for some reason the president
has gotten away with it now what I'm
saying is I personally believe I
personally don't think that having a
president at all is a really decent way
to run politics because if we
acknowledge the fact that America as a
whole it's pretty much a huge social
experiment I would say that the way
we've done a politics pretty much since
the beginning has not gone as well as we
would Pike because if you think about
how many presidents can you nae over the
course of this country's history the
devack descent anything good
systemically good for the American
people so let me interrupt right there
because here's the problem we have a
country that is now 340 million people
we have the office of the presidency
which is you could argue the highest
office in the land but a lot of what
happens in our country is happening in
the House and Senate a lot of it is
happening in governorships a lot of it
is happening in City Council's etc so I
actually think it's probably the wrong
standard to apply to presidency I mean
listen I could answer your question as
you asked it and I could say here's what
Obama did that was good here's what
Clinton did but it's all arguably going
to feel like okay you're pushing the
ball forward in one area but here's
things that didn't go as well whatever
the case may be that is actually the
concern with Trump which is aside from
the tax plan or his decision about Syria
he will have coarsened what counts as
political discourse ruined alliances
with other countries that have been
built over decades or longer changed the
appreciation that we have for separation
of powers by completely flouting it like
these are the big picture things that
will outlast Trump that at a top-down
perspective are going to be they're
going to take a long time to fix and so
when you say name me any president
that's done stuff that's good well okay
that that's only one part of what the
president is does and represents the
other thing the president does is sets
the sort of tone and political
environment in which all of the lower
legislators operate and that's where
Trump has done so much damage so I just
disagree with you about the framing of
the question
well that wasn't even my primary point
that was that was more to emphasize the
idea that that was more to prove my
argument that our current system of
politics isn't really all that good well
there's no I agree with you there I
agree with you there and I hate to cut
you off but I do have to run I agree
with you there and there are so many
ways in which that's the case whether
it's campaign
finance separation of powers the
judiciary all these different ways I
just think that it's the wrong framing
to enter it listen I apologize that I've
got a run but we we are short on time I
do want to hear from you again Aaron the
trucker we will put you in our system
that way that does it for today sorry
for everybody I was not able to get to
but alas we always have more people
wanting to get on than the number that
we have time for we will take calls
again